good morning
for the two or three of you out there
who don't know me I'm bill Hecht class
of 61 and I'm your senior employee as
head of the Alumni Association
you might wonder how a guy from the
class of 61 got a red coat a number of
years ago the class of 24 which is
celebrating its 70th this year had some
issues that needed settling and somehow
or other I was able to settle them for
that class and it's a great privilege
and tribute they made me an honorary
member of that class insisting that I
always wear a freshman tie so I now have
my own two connections a six and A one
my graduate degree was in 76 in my
undergraduate and 61 and a 24 which I'm
just as proud of and I'm busting my
buttons to say that in in 95 my daughter
will get a masters from this place so
I'll have another MIT connection I I
wonder if you all know that last night's
pops was not only a very special night
for us but it was actually a test for
the potential new conductor of the Pops
and
it is said that he practiced Arthur
Fiedler's hand motions studiously before
the mirror and I think that I'm going to
take on the job of being his agent and
represent him because I think we can get
a hell of a good contract finally it's
my great pleasure in addition to
welcoming you all here today to
introduce Chuck vest Chuck is president
of MIT as you know he came to us about
four years ago and he may be a little
wistful today as you know many people
who come in the fall of four years ago
graduated about a week ago his class the
class of 94 did leave Chuck I guess
fortunately for us but perhaps not so
fortunately for him still remains with
us so let me introduce Chuck vest
president of MIT
thank you very much bill I'm just signed
up for the new five-year master of
engineering program that's all I've been
for years wanting to get up the nerve to
ask Bill exactly what this great favor
he did for that class is but because I'm
not sure of its legality I've been
afraid to ask a more serious note and a
very happy one I understand that we have
a record number of alums and families
here for reunions and Technology Day you
are over 3,000 strong my congratulations
and we all have an exciting day ahead of
us the speakers for today's program are
truly a stellar group of men and women
who will talk about art and culture in
the Academy and specifically at MIT here
at MIT where the arts have evolved over
a hundred years from a single
extracurricular activity in 1884 the MIT
banjo Club to a panoply of artistic and
cultural endeavors that you're going to
have a chance to sample here today in
1994 special thanks go to Jorge
Rodriguez chairman of the Technology Day
Committee and to all the members of the
Technology Day committee the Council for
the Arts for putting together such an
astounding and exciting program I might
add that the watercolors reproduced in
the Technology Day poster was painted by
one of our graduate students in the
School of Architecture and planning Leon
quanzhen and that there are other
examples of his work on display today in
the lobby now to some it might seem odd
that in this bastion of Science and
Engineering we bring together our alumni
and alumnae to celebrate the Arts but
most of you probably had at least a
brush with the Arts at MIT and many of
you I'm sure became more deeply involved
in our music and theater arts programs
and now more than ever our students and
our faculty are engaged in the wide
range
of artistic and cultural pursuits in the
visual arts and architecture music
theater creative writing and photography
as well as in the emerging media of
interactive video holography and hyper
instruments still some of you might ask
why well it is true that MIT is best
known throughout the world for the
caliber of the engineers and scientists
we send out from this place the
Institute has in fact produced a study
flow of artists architects musicians
dancers actors and others who are best
known for their artistic endeavors we
have string players and wind players
composers and conductors and orchestras
around the country we have actors on
Broadway and in Hollywood and we have
MIT graduates on the faculties of music
schools and many other universities of
course most MIT students continue to
pursue traditional careers and
engineering and science but we are no
less serious about teaching music
theater and the arts to these students
the arts when taught seriously and
deeply offer our students opportunities
to expand their imagination broaden
their perspective and imagine ever
widening new possibilities this is true
for all of us when we develop our
ability to think creatively we are able
to find new solutions to the problems on
which we are working both in our
laboratories and in other aspects of our
lives take for example the fields of
engineering and particularly engineering
education we are moving very
dramatically toward a more integrative
style of education with increased
emphasis on design and synthesis and a
little bit less emphasis on analysis and
reductionist science I think that art
and an appreciation for the aesthetic
components of all that people do is very
helpful in this regard as we work to
improve the quality of designs and
products is going to be increasingly
important for engineers to cooperate
with artists to tackle the vase
jool tactile and aesthetic qualities of
their work but quite aside from their
role in scientific and engineering
endeavors the art should of course still
be an important part of our lives and of
our education why because they are part
of our humanity they reflect our human
experience the arts give us a different
kind of connection with the world and
they can help us to understand the many
cultures that make up our community and
our world the arts allow people from
very different perspectives and
backgrounds to communicate and to
interact with an almost built-in degree
of mutual respect this is important for
our graduates as they take their skills
into an increasingly interdependent
global and multicultural world and this
is very important for MIT the more
innovative we are in celebrating and
encouraging the richness and diversity
of our community the better off all of
us will be in some the arts at MIT are
essential elements of our education and
of our community life not only are they
healthy here they are thriving this is
great testimony to the talent the
dedication and the enthusiasm of a great
many faculty and students and it is
particular to monie to one person who
has done an extraordinary job in
stimulating and supporting the arts
since she arrived here at MIT in 1989 I
refer of course to my colleague
professor Ellen Harris associate provost
for the Arts at MIT Ellen is a
distinguished scholar of music who's
also known widely as a soprano soloist
she came to us from the University of
Chicago where she was a professor of
music and head of the department of
music as a scholar she's been recognized
for her work on the music of Handel as a
singer she is best known for her
dramatic stage performances those of you
who were here for commencement last week
and heard her sing the national anthem
know precisely what I mean
Ellen's arrival on campus was the final
fulfillment of a set of recommendations
made in 1987 by an arts review committee
which recommended the appointment of a
senior officer it would also be a
faculty member in either the performing
or visual arts someone to take broad
responsibility as an advocate leader and
coordinator for the creative arts
program here at MIT
believe me Ellen Harris serves superbly
in that role
ladies and gentlemen professor Ellen
Harris
Thank You Chuck
good morning oh good it's often been
said that at MIT one one's education is
like taking a drink from a fire hose
what I have noticed is that so is tech
day we have you here at before 9:00 in
the morning after having you out very
late last night and I appreciate seeing
you all here so so bright and raring to
go I'm proud and privileged to welcome
you to the wonder of it all the Arts at
MIT Technology Day 1994 and I want to
add my thanks to Jorge Rodriguez the
chair of the alumni tech day committee
and also to Eliza Dame who does so much
more than I can possibly say to make
tech day work year after year many
people like to talk about the Arts at
MIT as if it's an anomaly as if it's a
surprise or as if it's something new but
of course you know better than anyone
else that that is not the case the arts
have been a part of MIT since its
founding MIT was the first school to
establish a school of architecture in
1868 it actually began offering courses
in architecture in its first year 1865
in that same year we were offering
courses in photography and in drawing in
1884 we not only established the banjo
Club but we established the glee club in
1928 we established drama shop the
forerunner of our theatre curriculum
today and in 1948 John Corley came to
MIT to establish the MIT band an
organization that he continues to
conduct today
in 1950 the hayden gallery opened which
was the forerunner of our now
internationally renowned list Visual
Arts Center but perhaps most importantly
in 1944 50 years ago today MIT first
established its 8th semester sequence in
humanities those of you who have been at
the Institute since 1944 will remember
you're eight courses in the humanities
they used to be different than they are
today but in 1944 they included I think
a first-year course in writing and
English literature second year course in
history third year course where you
could choose from a number of subjects
including economics and in the fourth
year a wider selection of courses
including a year-long course in music
because of this 8th semester sequence of
courses which parallels the 8th semester
courses in science MIT has had for many
years a program in education which has
been referred to here as dual literacy
MIT students have been asked to be
literate not only in science but in
humanities and in the arts in fact MIT
may be one of the few educational
institutions in the country that asks
this of its students it is very very
easy at many liberal arts institutions
to avoid the sciences not so easy at MIT
to avoid the humanities in fact this
dual literacy has meant that we have
within our students and alums many
people who have gone on to careers in
the arts in fact in the class of 1994 I
can think of four cases immediately to
young men who have double majored in
mathematics and mu
both of whom are going on right now to
graduate school one to the University of
Chicago and one to Duke in music
composition we have another student who
majored in civil engineering who has
received a full scholarship to pursue
writing at Boston University and we have
another student who majored in theater
at MIT who is going on to pursue his
work in theater who hopes to establish
his own theater company in the
countryside of Mexico I sometimes think
we must graduate the most scientifically
literate artists in the world but this
is not something that was just true of
the class of 1994 and I was looking at
the reunion classes for some other
examples and obviously we have a lot of
people today here from the class of 1944
right
well one of your members jeonbu Vicki
who graduated with a major in management
has gone on to be a very well-known
composer and conductor who has been for
many years on the Faculty of the Berklee
School of Music from the class of 64 64
do I hear the class of 64 we have we
have John Miller who double majored in
humanities and engineering who has made
his career as principal bassoonist with
the Minnesota Orchestra class of 69 you
had with you for some time James Woods
who was majoring in political science
before he went on to become a very
well-known actor in 79 I think we need
more energy folks
Liz Marussia who went on to become an
practicing artist on the west coast who
paints beautiful canvases in watercolor
and gouache expressing time and space
and finally class of 89 5 years Ken
Goodson who majored in both mechanical
engineering and music received his
master's science in 91 in mechanical
engineering his PhD in 93 is now
studying and performing as a baritone
soloist in Germany I love about Ken that
when he performed at Tanglewood as an
MIT grad it is only appropriate that
when singing in Stravinsky's work the
flood Ken Goodson play the role of God
but obviously MIT does not graduate all
of its students to go on in the arts you
don't need to be an arts professional to
benefit from the arts and whether you
worked in Doc Edgerton strobe
photography lab or perhaps became
interested in physics through Bernice
Abbott's extraordinary photographs a
physical phenomena that were published
in many high school textbooks and that
were taken at MIT or whether you played
in the symphony or sang in the glee club
or acted in a theatrical production I am
sure that at some point art touched your
life at MIT and has continued to touch
your life thereafter Art's offer us
discipline anyone who has practiced the
piano knows that arts offer us
imagination they offer us the
flexibility of a pursuit where there is
not one right answer but they also offer
us new ways of organization of
organization of sound and space and time
the arts offer us a doorway into
cultures other than our own that enable
us not only to tolerate but respect
difference the arts challenge us
surprise us sometimes they anger us but
the arts also bring us Wonder and joy
and today we hope to explore through our
presentations the Wonder and joy of the
Arts today at MIT this of course leads
me directly to our first speaker Philip
Morrison Institute professor emeritus at
MIT you are probably familiar with his
work in astrophysics and cosmology may
be less familiar with his work as a
filmmaker I first came to know Philip
through a copy of a keynote address that
he gave in 1986 for the fifteenth
anniversary of the Council for the Arts
at MIT an organization founded in 1971
to advise and support and
in the expansion of its arts programs at
that time he he said and I quote it's
clear that if an institution like this
one which deals with the material world
did not have the side of art it would be
a self-defeating proposition which in
the end would be all genetic seed and no
fruit to the apple and an apple is not
made that way I think that I can do no
better in introducing professor Morrison
than to quote his colleague Victor
Weisskopf who's said of him scientific
knowledge and understanding is not a
purely cerebral affair it is soaked with
emotion excitement and nervous tension
as everybody knows who has ever heard
professor Morrison speak ladies and
gentlemen please help me to welcome
professor Morrison
thank you very much much equipment here
all of it seems to work especially
impressed by the video projection system
the wonder of it all at MIT arts at MIT
is very nice style doesn't say much it's
very few speakers I would certainly like
to fix firmly on to the word wonder
because clearly that's the kind of
motive which lies behind nearly that all
the things that go on at MIT translated
as eventually they are into the hard
tasks of earning a living and making
this world work the old classical
Chinese scholars always like to pretend
that the ideas they had were very old so
they found some mysterious figure of the
past so nobody knew much about typically
the Yellow Emperor and they said well
the Yellow Emperor first said and then
they made up their own books we don't do
that now we have a much more
forward-looking that we don't look back
in general it's always new that's the
same error in Reverse people have this
tendency for a bipolar positioning
bipolar stability of large axes because
everything is both has something old -
something new or it's not in pursued
very far that's the typical lesson ask a
historian he'll take it back for you ask
a project or the future he'll push it
forward both things lie in time I wanted
however and I didn't always know this I
became more and more convinced in the
past recent times a few years maybe the
proposition that this issue that we now
debate is extraordinarily old I could
invoke no newer a phrase for it than
this Latin tag of the Institute
then the Mets Manolos mind and hand to
talk about it because of course that is
the exquisite pleasure of the MIT
ambience that minds and hands are
equally well occupied that means to say
that you a lot of things a lot of
mechanical things are done a lot of
things in the material world or with the
refractory symbols of the world they're
hammered away at whether it be metal or
melodies or whatever it is but that's
not done by and large by rote obviously
some rope goes into all operations
experts become routine eyes but thought
is that the basis and it turns out that
that unity which is a profound unity
between art and the the triune quality
of modifying and knowing the world
physically craft engineering and science
in their relationships goes back a very
long time and I brought along a few
sides to justify that and to get us well
started so it's not a new task that
we're looking into this wonderful
picture in the center collection of
rocks deserves some close attention
those rocks are not natural rocks the
fact that they're quite similar I think
is pretty evidence it's also quite
evident if you look more closely not
easy to see perhaps it's better to
handle them we can't do that but I think
it's enough to suggest it in the context
like this you can see the three edges
here the double ones there
everyone has faceted edges this one has
in fact it's like double a kind of blade
like edge and so on this is a pile of
rocks a section of collection made by
the excavators in Olduvai Gorge in the
rift of East Africa these were not found
that way they were found in stratum
after stratum carefully located
carefully arranged in position so they
could be dated but the photographer had
simply gathered a lot of them to us an
impression of how many hundreds indeed
many thousands of these stone tools are
found now the remarkable part about them
of courses men's at Manos men's is
pretty thin still these are not even our
own species these are our distant
forebears they were poor they first
walked the earth fearful of the beasts
pretty soon that stopped and the beasts
tended to avoid them before that perhaps
even they scavenged on the kill of the
lion but sooner or later this kind of
operation symbolized here mind and hand
began to change where they were and they
did marvelous things on a very slow
timescale the piece is represented in
this collection just that arbitrary
piece of a large collection are measured
not by centuries but by thousands of
centuries yes by hundreds of thousands
of years a few hundred thousand years
corresponds to a typical collection at
Olduvai which might extend a million
years or more but to be generous will
say a few thousand centuries now the
striking point of this is that these
tools without very much change are found
over very large part of the world as the
next slide will show there it is here
are famous sights anyone who has read
anything about early archaeology will
recognize these kinds of locations from
britain up here into Europe France at
the Pyrenees especially very important
in there all across Africa East Africa
here we have Olduvai itself and down to
Cape Town so from Britain to Cape Town
and from Cape Town across Asia Central
Asia India North China Peak Peking
further north still and into Java all
these the major sites each site feathers
out into many many little excavations
and from all of these places about the
same kind of tools are collected yes the
experts argue a bit and they can
somewhat classify them but it's really
quite hard to date them except by the
attendant pieces of mineral which Knable
you to date them by radioactive means
but you'll notice that that one site is
found in these islands or Australia
and I've left out the Americas no use to
put it on the map because not one site
of this kind has ever surely been found
in America no Australia the great
islands near Australia and the two
Americas do not belong to these people
who I don't wish to say are they are our
ancestors can't speak ill of them they
were in fact the Prometheans because
somewhere in the middle of their span
Homo erectus figured out how to make and
control fire and the hammer a MIT is
entirely secondary to the fire and all
that goes with that symbolically so I
don't show you those sites of course are
very many sites in America but none of
them show the bones or the tools of
these ancient folk we truly like the
Australians the Australian Aboriginals
the Native Americans are the modern
humans like all the rest of this place
has also been filled in by modern humans
I don't mean to say we're of course
we're not
most modern humans live in this part of
the world but the same species occupies
this whole region and only after a long
time after thousands of centuries it
managed they managed in the course of
some internal change which is what we
would call a change in species to Homo
sapiens they managed by means or not can
do well debated and interesting to study
they managed to be able to cross the
then much shallower coastal seas and
finally the great gulf of the timber
trench and come somehow by canoe or raft
to Australia and in the same way go
across the relenting Arctic where the
glaciers were melting and follow the
coastline of America and go down the
full length of both continents rather
quickly and that completed the
occupation of the world by modern humans
so we are the new world not because of
Columbus or any feature of historical
importance those are small matters the
real thing was we're new because the new
people who filled up the old lands very
well had a way also to get to new lands
never before occupied so our histories
go back only a few hundred centuries not
few thousand centuries there's an order
of a good difference between the kind of
thing you saw in the Olduvai rocks by
faces choppers hand axes they're called
and the kind of thing that came when a
new set of persons of whom we are all
descended we can prove by the deepest of
biological means how United the whole
world is in this in our single species
with subspecies and as we well know and
the next slide will show what you find
in these new sights
now please compare these which are nice
American pieces they were made about ten
or twelve fight well twelve or fourteen
thousand years ago these are found in
the region in Montana and of course
they're specialized for killing big-game
and if you'd like to know what the big
game was probably you do know it was
elephants pieces quite like this spear
points like this have been found in
contact with the bones of bison and
mammoths and of course where the other
rocks had ten or twenty rather cunning
blows struck with you and I could not do
which people can train themselves to do
today these have many hundreds of
knowing strokes to chip the blade just
correctly and even along the edge you
can see to sharpen it with a wonderful
thing a very detailed marks up there all
of which are significant in producing a
handy and useful blade so I have no
doubt to say this is craftsmanship
possibly even engineering at least it's
high-quality craftsmanship because we
know now that many of these blades have
to be heat treated in order to allow the
church and the Flint to respond to the
chipping but now I'd like to go a little
farther and show what they did not
happens at the preservations I have now
are again the same new people are people
but now coming from France and not from
Montana the following a bone object used
for working sinew and straightening
arrow shafts you can see the hole there
but it wasn't enough to make it
utilitarian it has this marvelous
leaping horse worked into the same
material
and I this is about 200 or 250 centuries
old from Bruni quelle a cave in France
we have art so much from France and
Spain because the caverns are so well
protected there they guarded the art
behind stalactites for many thousands of
years and the next slide perhaps even
more striking an image itself an elk of
the period the biologists will find
fossils that fit it quite well
beautifully drawn in charcoal and ochre
on the wall of the french cave this one
the famous cave of Lascaux so I rest the
case that the relationship the change
that came to human beings we don't
exactly know what it is most likely it
was the acquisition of a powerful
language which enabled to work
cooperatively and to model the future
gave rise to the craft and the art which
you have mistake ibly see here which
goes back not merely thousands of years
but tens of thousands of years this
particular piece is dated about fifteen
or eighteen thousand years ago the
previous one about twenty thousand years
ago
and all from that same flat of persons
who occupied the world maybe in all not
more than half a million of them by the
time the Americas were settled and we've
grown then from that half million to two
half trillion a very large number of
powers of ten in population thank you
now the linkage between the craft
engineering science art between hand and
mind expressed in this way I maintain
this Daman stably old indeed we can see
it even the beatings of science the time
of the Enlightenment of the late
Renaissance you couldn't buy a
microscope that wasn't worked up and
chased and engraved to bear somewhat
partly that was style I'm not denying it
partly that was royal patronage and not
denying that either nevertheless the
work of the hand was to be admired and
it was rare to have such skill and
craftsmanship in these new materials
with a new purp
and to some extent that we've lost that
feeling because of our high utilitarian
quality and they already great expense
of making the complex instruments which
now replace the sledgehammer of the MIT
seal or argument the sledgehammer
I don't want to run down to such a ver
still a very good indispensable
instrument what I would like to
emphasize though is that this connection
is a profound connection and I like to
describe a little bit why I think it's
so and why it parts the hand mind
relationship from a more symbolic one
which is not absent from either any of
you've tried to learn a craft or a skill
or above all and art knows how very
close the reaction of the hand and the
mind must be to make anything work the
way you choose and if you don't do that
another draft is to be made now of
course the those who deal in symbols
alone have some of the same quality but
this hand is much less present the
symbols are by nature more conventional
what is characteristic of art and
science and engineering together is they
represent almost always they're
presented to us and they need to be
presented to us in concrete form in
single concrete examples perhaps
something more than the poet Blake
called minut particulars which he felt
all art and science were compacted but
certainly not generalities generalities
edge towards philosophical description
true there's a big domain in between
there are theorems and propositions that
are indispensable that come out of
thought and which governed many of the
things we do but I think it's fair to
say that works of art and the data of
science and works of the engineer are
all concrete examples and if you don't
have those you have a very dry subject
indeed it consists of nothing of
theorems about mechanics without motions
or diagrams or examples or particulars
which I suffered through as a graduate
student once long ago at another
university when I was studying mechanics
we couldn't ask questions and we also
couldn't understand the propositions we
sure could learn the words
well no there are differences of course
I think of the principle characteristic
of art which I admit it is somewhat
rapidly losing but hasn't lost yet can
be seen in almost all parts of it its
products its particulars our perceptual
to the human being it's very hard to
imagine art translated through it's not
impossible you see it today translated
through some intermediate device which
turns it into printouts and numbers and
then you have to re graphic this is
hardly art the immediacy is gone though
of course a great deal over the world of
science going to the data of science go
beyond human perception involve
intermediation by instrumentation of
complicated kinds and exaggerated
calculations to bring together the
reading of the instruments or program
inside the computer which is doing the
same thing and by enlarge that's the
biggest distinction I can see on the
side of how the work is done
it is also true that they're United in
this niels bohr defined science not only
as an effort to order the world which
surely it is but there it does not deal
it does not differ from philosophy or
for that matter from poetry but it seeks
to bring in new experience which again
is close to art though perhaps rather
different from the Philosopher's work
and if we talk about engineering I think
we have to say to bring new means for
the gaining of experience this too is
necessary but all of this definitional
style would very much connect these two
or three it's hard for me to think of
them as three but certainly a multiple
view of these matters I'd like to go
still further and talk about their
internal the way it appears the
practitioners of it all of you as
students were practitioners all of you
now practically which in some direction
or another and I think you'll recognize
feel sympathy with what I say when I say
that they're a couple of apparently
polar divisions contradictions opposites
which have to be united in each of these
things curious but
quite realistic account of what people
do
for example the passive absorption of
information to learn a language to learn
mathematical formulation to learn the
use of a pen or a brush to learn the
language of the stage whatever it might
be to learn the notes of the scale and
the keys all of those things are done
can be done as a passive game where
someone feeds the information a book a
program a person and you gain it but at
the other side activity is indispensable
especially if you learn those things
with that beautiful word productivity so
you can again recombine them for
yourselves we know people who teach
physics at MIT and everywhere else that
the solving of problems owners it maybe
is a way to secure the active knowledge
of the things passively observed by
underlying and yellow marker the big
propositions in the textbook you've got
to put them together you've got to make
them work for you you have to feel
somewhat what we say at home with them
until that's happened no genuine
understanding will come in the answer
your multiple choice tests in familiar
language choosing the right one of six
is not a very powerful test for science
for engineering or for art it may be
good enough for learning certain
received bodies of truth fine not
against it entirely but it's clearly in
our day it's the basis of controversy
and surely overused so we don't we have
to have combined the passive and the
active and activity is the sign of
quinone of the hand in the mind the same
similar dichotomy goes between the
analytic and the synthetic it was sad in
popular psychology only a few years ago
it's quite popular in the magazines that
were two halves of the brain the left
and the right and one attended to the
holistic things the organization the
concepts and one attended to the details
the rigorous logical thinking one was
suitable for children one for grownups
and that was the general idea people
that of course are mostly writers
because they understood writing very
well they knew how hard it was to
formulate good senses and paragraphs and
they said well in the kindergarten they
can draw quite well and make images and
that's enough for that of course this is
a caricature it's a very bad proposition
analytics and synthetic again are
together the analyst indeed may take
things apart but the tools he uses were
themselves synthesized by earlier
designers who synthesized the the
scalpel or the method of least squares
whatever it might be putting together
something new that had not existed
before so I'd reject that as a as a
harsh division of the world and say no
both halves of the of the mind are
necessary all parts of the mind like
both hands and the unitarity of this is
visible invisible in the in the sense
that we all know that for every
geometrical statement in Euclid and
algebraic equivalent can be formed and
vice versa the symbols of language the
symbols of x and y and plus are no more
foreign than the lines and the angles
they're just different ways of
presentation and they have a one-for-one
correspondence of course the symbolism
of our world is so powerful now the
extents it goes beyond we can easily
draw you can do n dimensionality I
accept that and use it daily but this is
the issue now there is a feeling that
there's a difference in in tone and
there is some difference the scientists
and engineers seem serious they are
concerned with matters of the prosperity
and penury or sometimes life-and-death
or sometimes peace and war and this
seems more serious perhaps than the more
playful activity of the artist but I
recommend to you think you through our
own language the word play has wide
connotations the player may play media
or Hamlet hardly a light-hearted affair
something plumbing the depths of of
human behavior lightness of heart is not
the whole story the primary colors and
the
the sphere are fine things for the for
the elementary school indispensable for
the small child but they are not the
whole story of play play which is unique
in the vertebrates and best developed in
those closest to us is profound I worked
a lot with Charles Eames who said that
one of the most serious activities in
life was play and he demonstrated it
every day by what he did play is a means
of clearly what the word implies
model-making of the future what would it
be to do like that not to carry it out
not to make that fool investment but to
acquire the mastery in a more benign
more acceptable a more easily entered
environment and that is what play is and
since you cannot master the world in in
a stroke play is an indispensable
feature of human behavior from word play
of the infant and the mother in the home
to the most profound fart of an Einstein
or a composer of great value bah in the
course of his work as any exposure to
art demonstrates these things have and
the scientists too must have it I'd like
to say a word for playful engineering
which i think is an important issue of
our time that we have not yet fully
engaged it's not new there always has
been such a thing
but I'd like to show an example of it in
slide I hope you can recognize this
slide it's a very unusual slide was made
1936 it shows the greatest one of the
greatest works of playful engineering
the Eiffel Tower you can perhaps
recognize the Avenue shyeo down here and
the arches of the Eiffel Tower they're
all heavily illuminated in this time
time exposure from 1936 where of course
what you see is a pyrotechnic display
fireworks off all parts of the Eiffel
Tower
but of course the Eiffel Tower was built
strictly as a playful operation a
decoration for Paris from the egg team
for the 1889 World's Fair there by a
great structural engineer I worked
10,000 tons of
iron not of steel of wrought iron and
rivets and made playfully of course
managing to extract the fee from the
people who come so can keep going keep
yourself painted and indeed pay the
shareholders quite a considerable income
I understand over the years but
nevertheless it that's it's its
foundation it doesn't do anything but
stand there magnificently at first of
course attacked by half the artists and
writers in Paris and now inseparable
from the nature of the city and I'm sure
that you could not possibly tear it down
without a major revolution swirling
about the base of the tower now playful
engineering is not enough practiced in
our time in his practice some we all
know about we know about it in sports
where it's become a specialty and almost
lost its playful call because of its
heavy rewards and at MIT from the
impromptu and very light-hearted hack of
which ever I need not give you any
examples through the petal driven
aircraft of great renown to the
wonderful stroboscopic work of papa
flash the lake Doc Edgerton to the
sophisticated work which was whose 25th
anniversary is being celebrated tomorrow
at the Museum of the center of advanced
visual studies which I remember for some
three or four works of grand works not
single works but whole campaigns of
playful engineering mechanisms of
extraordinary wit and pleasure the use
of aerial photography as an art form not
as a geodetic study or a way of
measuring crops and sky art lasers and
balloons on grand scale just beginning
in this world in the last few years and
I am quite sure also that the Palais de
louvre has been recently subjected to
something which is architecture and
playful in its qualities and the same
time profoundly purposeful and I'm sure
that I am pay and it will and the
Mitchell will describe something about
that in their talk of recent work just
to come
now I'm going to close and I want to
close with a somewhat novel end which I
had not really planned but it was forced
out of me as I went through these
thoughts in the last few weeks I see one
danger the danger is an extraordinarily
clear one and I think we have found the
best way to avoid it I'll tell you what
those things what what that is and see
if you agree with me please think about
it it's something novel if it's
something of great importance to all of
us and it needs widespread attention and
that is it's clear that nowadays art
produces its own truths the artwork is
not judged by its comparison with
another canon necessarily yes it might
be in the school bazaar it might not
the schools are various so the
techniques are innumerable the subject
mattered the minute particulars are as
wide as can be and I think we should
accept that as the freedom that the
artist has of course he may follow a
strict form he may wish to do that or he
may break loose into something quite new
but in any case there's no other
criterion no external one the scientists
must the input is what counts the data
must be reliably presented the engineer
the object must work for the purpose in
which it was intended or some purpose
close to that but the artist it is the
output that counts does it work for the
purpose he intended to amuse to
entertain to teach whoever it might be
it doesn't matter how he got there he
doesn't responsibly to show you the data
on which he worked and on the other hand
this leads to a great danger at which a
very tiny example my wife Phyllis
Morrison has helped me produce for the
next last slide well it's the Eiffel
Tower again right in fact it's the same
you see the same pyrotechnic picture but
spontaneously we matter of a few seconds
Phyllis has managed to give a kind of
impression that there's a colorful
pyrotechnic display coming from the
great tower and of course you are all
well sophisticated for the images and
with
kurz to recognize that of course that's
nothing dude Eiffel Tower at all what
does it have to do with has to do with a
35-millimeter slide that represented the
Eiffel Tower in 1936 which he has then
modified with just a very small
spontaneous artistic work to make the
point here the image however is itself
it is there and it means something it's
actually quite striking and now the
trouble is we make images so well today
we make so many we can make them so
seamlessly we can change their
appearance in every way not only visual
images but even speaking more
metaphorically auditory and the rest
that there is a cutoff between the world
represented may not be represented but
even those things that when they are
represented world represented the image
are no longer good maps of show the
artists intervention is so powerful that
he has ended that now that is not new to
us we all experience it internally and
it is probably indispensable to the
human mind and the way we have evolved
it is what we call the world of dream in
dream visual images are produced which
have maybe some semblance of your
experience sometimes not perhaps but
when they have semblance we know very
well that those dreams are not the
relatively close approximations to what
is going on that the eyes which are
always limited and the video screen
which is equally and similarly limited
bring to you approximations of the real
world now what I am trying to say is a
danger that if we have as we do have the
growth of the greatest 20th century arts
the one that attracts most people and I
think has gradually gradually increased
its salience is the cinema and I
strongly suspect the 21st century will
make the video equal the cinema with its
music with its changes which is probable
3d nature and its motions and change
will probably transcend all previous
visual experiences will make an enormous
push upon the world where's the capital
of this world is only going to double or
triple and and plateau out there isn't
room for more there's not room in the
atmospheric balance of the heat sources
for more
these sources of information image are
enormous and they will continue and the
real question is that we not be swamped
in a dream world
well we no longer pay attention to what
the representation was of but only the
nation's representation itself that is
after all the artists task and I can't
think of a better way of understanding
that problem of conquering it than by
having people who know both sides of the
operation who have studied the arts to
see how much you can do to make
entertaining and wonderful things that
didn't exist but also how much you can
do to represent scrupulously and
meticulously the data of the real world
the actual performance of engineering
without hyperbole and public relations
and the rest to take only one side will
stay away from the other that will not
work
because people are too clever and
they'll transcend it what is the best is
to expose them both come right up front
and say yes this can be done the artist
has one direction the engineer scientist
has another both recognize their
enormous similarity but between their by
their mutual understanding we can have a
world which both contains dreams but is
not solely based on it and I think
that's the only kind of a world it which
is a safe for us to try to carry on the
legacy of the canyon at Olduvai